pensez à tous les humains de toutes les
mamans s'étaient tous les jours tous les
jours j'en avais assez
je me disais mais c'est pas possible
c'est en prison que de marcher sur la
tête qu'est ce que ça à voix le coc vide
acclamer les gens se sont éloignés l'un
de l'autre je ne comprends pas enfin
nous avons quand même satisfaction et je
suis content ça me manque que ça me
manquait donc suffire mieux que ça il y
en a hélas ce matin je me suis lâché
mais complètement loupé si je ne venais
pas la plage je connais je faisais
prendre tout simplement prendre un bain
je me je m'attardais jamais sur la plage
c'est un bas et je m'en allais je
pouvais je coupe jusqu'à maintenant de
coups et puis et puis je prendre mais
c'est interdit c'est interdit la no
aller sur la plage c'était interdit mais
la baignade était interdite quand quand
on interdit la meilleure pour le précise
la baignade était interdite
la plage je trouve aberrant qu on
autorise j'allais se bousculer dans les
supermarchés aller voter et puis on
était haut dit d'aller à la mer
c'est complètement débile donc il ya
beaucoup de gens qui viennent sais pas
si c'est vrai on sait pas si c'est
ouvert qu'on s'en fiche complètement
on a besoin de l'amélioration viendra le
matin pour refaire du sport et nous
pensons tous que c'est une bonne façon
la santé la mairie très bonne d'éclairer
les bonnes et les pâtes froides voilà on
y est ce une heure ou une heure et demie
et puis après on rentre à la maison on
passe une belle journée